dans ces territoires qui semble isolé il
se passe parfois des choses surprenantes
lorsque l'on parvient à connecter les
talents je me mets au travail rester
sage chaque matin dans sa maison de
fontaine et clerval audrey la mère de
famille devient chef d'entreprise elle
est créatrice de bijoux et grâce à un
accord avec une célèbre enseigne
autrichienne elle peut réaliser ces
petites merveilles pouvoir travailler
les perles c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours aimé je suis dans la création
depuis très longtemps et en fait créé
mon entreprise dans la création de
bijoux c'est un aboutissement c'est
c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu faire
donc après des périodes de travail
salarié je me suis jamais senti à ma
place et maintenant je me sens à ma
place dans ce domaine et ça me permet
d'être présente pour les enfants vous
demandez comment se joue essentiellement
sur internet à une clientèle plutôt
étrangères dans les pays arabes russes
[Musique]
mais pour parvenir à capter l'attention
de l'internaute moscovite l'artisanat
d'art a bénéficié d'un vrai coup de main
celui de catherine humbert qui travaille
à la chambre de métiers
sa mission est justement de soutenir les
entrepreneurs notamment dans les zones
rurales
s'ajoutent les dernières faussent pas
très bien on va aider de chefs
d'entreprises donc à choisir sur ça le
meilleur statut juridique à travers
niveau des finances également on va
parler de chiffres d'affaires ont pas le
seuil de rentabilité non c'est un petit
peu barbare mais voilà donc c'est ce que
tout un accompagnement qui réalise et
donc qui est individuelle et de
proximité
mais pour que la petite entreprise
prennent des couleurs
il fallait aussi un soutien
administratif cette maison de service
qui se trouve à quelques kilomètres de
là a donc elle aussi joué un rôle
important
on va intervenir dans un autre champ
parce que on voit bien à les chefs
d'entreprise mais il a une vie familiale
est là et les citoyennes donc nous on va
intervenir plus tôt sur ce volet-là sur
un accès à la mutuelle sur un accès au
transport et les choses comme ça donc
finalement on va faire du sur mesure on
va prendre la personne dans seront dans
sa globalité
et puis on va lui permettre d'être plus
sereine après pour avoir ce rôle de chef
d'entreprise depuis sa fenêtre virtuelle
qui donne sur la planète
audrey entend bien se faire une petite
place dans l'univers des pigeons le
calme de ce petit village du doubs me
permet d'être tranquilles d'avoir
l'esprit l'esprit tranquille être
pouvoir crir
créée en toute sérénité et surtout avec
la nature à côté le voilà